[Music]
can you name a similarity between apple
Google Nvidia Cisco and Oracle well yes
there are all multi-hundred billion
dollar Fortune 100 companies but they
were also all funded by Sequoia capital
Sequoia has also funded a Dashlane
doordash GitHub Instagram PayPal Reddit
SpaceX Square WhatsApp Yahoo YouTube
zoom and all of these other companies as
well considering this many would argue
that Sequoia is by far the most
successful VC firm of all time but it's
not all sunshines and rainbows while
it's cool to say that you've been
involved in all of these companies the
reality is that to get here there's way
more failures in fact 75 of all VC
backed startups fail so for every Apple
they score they have to deal with three
wannabe apples who end up consuming tens
of millions each